un momento muy complejo que pone más
inestabilidad y drama al gobierno
británico y al futuro político de lis
tras cuya permanencia en el 10 de Down
Street Todavía está en veremos su
permanencia está en riesgo hace varios
días en esta carta de renuncia sobre la
Problem que llevaba 43 días en el
gobierno aduce razones éticas pero la
carta está llena de críticas alis tras y
lo que hace pensar es que la razón de
fondo no fue esa filtración del correo
sino otra dice además que cuando se está
en el gobierno si se cometen errores
deben asumirse dice textualmente que
pretender que no hemos cometido errores
como si nadie pudiera darse cuenta de
que los hemos cometido y esperar que las
cosas salgan bien por arte de magia no
es política seria y además dice que
tiene serias preocupaciones sobre la
dirección del gobierno del issstras como
lo mencionas y lo cierto Es que en una
semana les trata dos ministros
fundamentales para un gobierno el de
finanzas y del interior lo que nos
muestra lo débil políticamente y la
inestabilidad que tiene el gobierno de
lis tras
acaba de ser designado como ministro del
interior fue el ministro de transporte
durante el gobierno de Johnson